[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast we have for you today a round
table of some remarkable public
intellectuals many of whom you will know
some of them may be new to you
we have Glenn Lowry who is the Merton
peace stolz professor of economics at
Brown University and the host of the
Glenn show on blogging heads TV we have
John Wood Jr who is the National
ambassador of braver angels and a
quitter contributor at Colette magazine
we have Coleman Hughes who is a fellow
at the Manhattan Institute and a
contributing editor at City Journal we
have Chloe Valery who is the founder of
theory of Enchantment Thomas Chatterton
Williams who is contributing writer at
the New York Times Magazine and a
columnist at Harper's and we have
Camille Foster who is a partner at free
think and an unindicted co-conspirator
co-conspirator at the Fifth Column
podcast and John McWhorter who is
professor of linguistics at Columbia
University thank you all for joining me
we have quite a situation on our hands
here in the US and in the West more
generally and to be honest I'm not
exactly sure how to start this
conversation for one thing the
conversation is obviously in large
measure about race but I don't even feel
comfortable asserting what anyone else's
race is and I'm not even sure I know
what mine is supposed to be so forgive
me for having invited you here on the
basis of having some African ancestry I
believe that that fact is is sufficient
to set the conversation in motion and at
some level that makes me the token white
in this conversation so I guess is that
is that some kind of progress all of us
have entirely African ancestry that
Thank You Chloe I probably should have
said recent African ancestry and I guess
I should ask recent African ancestry is
it fair to
say that you know I'm an evolutionary
biologist so recent to me means
something like the last thousand years
is it fair to assume that each of you
traces your ancestry to Africa and the
leat in the last thousand years okay
fair enough all right now I should also
probably warn you upfront that my sense
is that we are involved in a renewed
racial conflict in the US and that it is
very badly cast and that in fact it is a
distraction from a much deeper issue
which has to do with long-standing and
extensive political corruption which has
frozen citizens out of the well being
that is produced by their labor in our
markets and that we are in effect being
misled into fighting each other when
there is a much more obvious enemy so in
light of that I will at some point
during this conversation want to talk to
you about what solution might lead us
out of this catastrophe but before I get
to a discussion of community 2020 and
what it might have to do with our
situation I'm very interested to have a
different conversation with you all in
essence I invited you because I know you
all to be incredibly courageous and to
be very deep thinkers on many issues
including race my hope is that one thing
will strike people who see this podcast
which is that we have assembled here on
our screen an incredible group of
courageous public intellectuals who are
also African American in part or in
whole however it is that you define
yourselves and that the fact that the
african-american community or is it fair
for me to say black
is that an acceptable term yeah I do - I
do - it's the one I grew up with and it
feels it feels right to me as well that
what I know from my own life and from
interacting with many of you is that for
some reason and I confess it's a reason
I do not know the black community has
produced more top-flight public
intellectuals than any other population
I know of I don't know the cause but the
fact that that is the case is striking
and I hope people will notice and start
thinking about what may be going on one
hypothesis is that it has something to
do with adversity I'd be interested to
hear what you all think but before we
get there what I'd like is each of you
to give a sense of where you think we
might be given the George Floyd protests
the black lives matter movement and the
national conversation I just want to
have an idea of where you think we might
be headed as a nation so you're all in
different orientations on each other
screens why don't we go with the
orientation on my screen Glenn are you
willing to start here I'll start I don't
want to stand in the way of the
brilliant observation so I'm sure we'll
follow
we're in deep doo-doo man I mean we're
we're we're in the grips of something I
think I'm not sure I can give all the
parameters and I don't want to take too
long but that I think is a very serious
problem for the country I think we're
out of touch with reality
I think demagoguery is afoot I think
there's a lot of sophomoric reflections
about social problem and organization
that has just consumed all the air in
the room and we're we're boxing as
shadows and whatnot then I'll just give
one illustration of this and I'll stop
there supposed to be an epidemic of
racist police killings of black people I
don't think that's true I think that's
literally false I don't think these
events that we're observing or even
properly classified as racial events I
think the unreflective imputation of
racial animus to people who happen to be
in one group or another and who find
themselves in
is a deep problem for our society I
think we're losing our way but like I
say I'm just the first of many people
who will make much more important
observation so I'll desist thanks Glen
John would my feeling is that this is
let me go ahead and say something
optimistic to try and counterbalance I
think some of the justifiable pessimism
that people may be feeling this moment I
think this is a moment of an
extraordinary opportunity an
extraordinary danger and I think that we
can focus on the opportunity in a way
that calls forth some things that need
to happen right now I think there is
this zealous pursuit of an ideological
victory in favor of a certain version of
social of social justice which is
calling for the sort of vast
condemnation of the white supremacist
state it gives the impression that
America is irredeemable because its
whiteness is something that imbues it
with a certain guilt that can only be
removed through a sort of mass atonement
and capitulation to a series of demands
my feeling is that the is that America
is not a fundamentally racist nation but
that black America faces problems that
are complex and systemic both of these
things can be true at the same time and
I think that a moment like this is a
moment in which the nation is paying
greater attention to the plight of black
America and if that happens in a way to
where those energies can be diverted
towards sensitive listening and an
appreciation of the nuances that govern
our reality then we can make the space
for genuine progress to occur but we
have to move past the demagoguery and
the demonization that is characterized
the conversation so far that is so
heavily invested in the in this sort of
tribal vilifying of certain groups if we
if we can get past that then we can use
the attention at the moment to actually
break through to something better
great Coleman you're up yes so I think
we face many serious problems as a
country for most at this moment is the
fact that policing is a difficult job
and we have you know the way the police
are structured often doesn't provide
incentives for police to be at their
best we face tricky problems we face
problems that are much harder than I
think would be suggested if you listen
to the dominant rhetoric coming out of
the left-wing activist movement right
now we we live in a country with more
guns than people where when police pull
someone over they have to some extent
rational fear that the person might have
a pistol hidden in the glove compartment
and certain police officers deal with
that as well as it could possibly be
dealt with and other police officers are
horrible at their jobs but we that
that's a uniquely American situation
because of how much of a gun country we
are is it's a situation that there is no
Pat or easy solution to and I think I'm
more optimistic about the prospect of
never seeing a George Floyd or Tony
Tempah like incident again where
somewhere where a cop is just has his
knee on someone's neck or upper back and
essentially kills them in that way I'm I
think it's possible to to come to a
place where we never see an incident or
almost never seen an incident like that
I'm not at all optimistic about getting
to a place where we never see an unarmed
America in of any particular race
getting shot by a cop but the problem is
I think you know the media has prepared
black people to think of this kind of
event as something that only or
overwhelmingly happens to black people
and they're therefore to react as if our
people are being
hunted by selectively omitting all the
cases where this happens to white people
and I see lots of what seemed like
purely symbolic fake solutions to these
problems being offered reparations how
does that help police brutality
you know hiring more black people at in
c-suite positions at corporations
where's the link between that and fixing
broken public schools so I see lots of
fake solutions being offered to real
problems and that worries me because
they appear in people's minds to be real
solutions great Thomas yeah well to pick
a phone where Coleman left off I
actually do think that that something
some sort of reparations might go a long
way towards or healing some of the
divisions in our society I start from
the premise that race isn't real what
racism is and that is specific people
that have been in this country since the
collision of Europe and Africa 400 some
odd years ago happened have been failed
by their government in this specific
geography and then a lot of the kind of
inequality could be fixed with some type
of solution that I don't have right now
to go off the top of my head with but
that the idea of reparations might do
something towards helping racial
division I also think from where I sit
you know just looking back at America
it's extraordinary once you leave to
realize how violent is society it is and
how extraordinarily violent the police
are towards all American citizens
compared to other wealthy societies so
the police kill upwards of a thousand
people a year over 500 of those thousand
will be white 10 out of every million of
those of those thousand will be Native
American it's the the proportion is six
out of a million for for blacks 2.2 out
of a million for whites and Asians are
very rarely
killed by police so there is a problem
and whites get the bulk of the numbers
but blacks are disproportionately killed
not in the worst situation compared
compared to Native Americans you can
imagine a situation where a widespread
call for policing reform should be
something that all American citizens are
invested in and so I think that part of
the rhetoric has already been said here
part of the rhetoric that this is a
uniquely or specifically black problem
does more to hinder lasting and an
important solution than trying to find
common ground and common problems to
excellent John McWhorter I think what
we're seeing right now at this moment is
that a certain radical strain of anti
racism that's been present for a long
time has been present for decades it's
intellectually mediocre but it's
extremely frightening to other people
because one of its main tenets is that
to not agree with it makes you a racist
so we're in a society where to be called
a racist is essentially equivalent to
being called a pedophile and you have
this minority of people with this
frankly half-cocked notion of how we
should deal with race in the society
that entails burning everything down and
starting again policing language in a
way that would make it impossible to say
anything the whole philosophy is based
on paradoxes that don't make any sense
it's it's all quite a mess but there's
always been a certain kind of person
many of them white many of them black
who subscribe to the square because of
what happened to George Floyd and the
response to it which I think was
conditioned actually somewhat
fortuitously by how everybody has been
feeling after quarantine and it's been a
really interesting series of apon
stances
because of that space I think that these
new anti-racist sense this as a moment
when they can actually take over they
sense it as a useful time when they can
make America
believe what they believe and I don't
want to make it sound like they're evil
most people like that are very nice
people who sincerely believe that what
they're thinking is correct because
frankly a lot of them have been trained
not to think very hard about race it's
all very intellectually mediocre but
they're not gonna look over and so the
point that we're at right now is that
these people are threatening to tear
down any institution that matters and
create this kind of Orwellian America
they don't know the evil that they're
doing they're not evil people they don't
understand that their ideas won't work
but it is the time for all good men and
women and humans to face this mob down
and that hasn't been happening before
generally the ordinary person who knows
that all that stuff is nonsense goes
along with it because they want to keep
their job and they have kids to raise
they have bigger fish to fry it's
completely understandable but that's not
gonna work this time and so I'm
wondering whether the ordinary person
who knows that all of that stuff is a
new kind of Stalinism is gonna have it
in them to start saying no they might
not in which case I really do fear for
what's gonna happen on the other hand I
see signs that they might there might be
a way of keeping this from going any
further than it already herds I'd like
to see what happens this calendar year
as we go into the fall how many people
are going to be capable of standing up
to this sort of thing because after a
few people did after a few organizations
did then there would be a copycat
phenomenon once once people start to see
if the sky won't fall in if somebody
says you're a racist and you just stand
there and say okay once they realize
that the world will keep spinning
that'll start happening more I hope it
does all right Chloe
so I would say to piggyback on what has
already been said that for me this looks
like a crisis of meaning in the country
so I think that we are as citizens
increasingly atomized and isolated both
socially certainly due to Coba 19 but
we've been isolated prior to that
and I also think that there's a
spiritual malnourishment in the country
that manifests itself in certain ways
one of which is racially I think that
the way in which this idea of anti
racism has been proliferating over the
past few months is a direct product of
that spiritual male nourishment and so
without addressing that issue we'll
continue to have these issues pop up
every so often and I agree that this
will be able to be sort of kept at bay
if the average person is able to stand
up for themselves and say no but I'm not
sure if the average person actually has
that fortitude and that confidence to do
so I will say that I have been
approached specifically because of
theory of Enchantment and the way it
actually teaches texts by a lot of the
traditional african-american scholars of
you know the Harlem Renaissance movement
and such I have been I have been
approached by people looking for
alternatives to some of the anti-racist
programming that's been promoted by even
Kendi in the workplace and in
corporations and in schools I have been
approached by people so in the name of
diversity and inclusion you know asking
me for an alternative through the theory
of Enchantment lays so that is very I
think hopeful just to see that people
are actually looking for alternatives
and it's possible that the rise of folks
like Abram kindy and Robyn D'Angelo is
actually very going to be short-lived I
don't know what we shall see but I also
think and a more hopeful sort of point
that the people writ large the American
people in in the same way that we are
susceptible to being sort of whipped
into a frenzy by the media and and
susceptible to being polarized and and
sort of turning against each other again
because of that spiritual nourishment
because we gravitates what politics as a
form of religion now
I think we are also encouraged I've seen
encouraging signs that we're all so
tired of a lot of this being whipped
into a frenzy and tired of you know
tearing each other apart at the seams
and are really hungry for something that
would actually be unifying and bring us
together so I think that that is cause
for great hope great Camille um I I do
like batting cleanup in a situation like
this because so many great things have
already been said and while there's some
disagreement in a couple of specific
places I think I am in broad agreement
with the general theme I will say that I
I think it's important to pay some
attention to the context we find
ourselves in I mean this the country is
in a very vulnerable position
we've just had actually are still in the
throes of a global pandemic we're at the
very beginning I think a pretty profound
economic crisis that might play a play
out over the course of the next decade
and the specific manifestations of
concern like the waves of it the perixx
paroxysm it are are important but
interestingly I don't know that the race
is so central to it it's a piece of this
conversation but it isn't all of it just
as policing is a piece of the
conversation but it isn't all of it um
we've seen ourselves sort of currying
from a place where people are
particularly concerned about an imagined
genocide against all black people to
tearing down statues and monuments to
reallocation of wealth to the
inculcation of these new ideas like the
notion that individuality itself is
somehow a retrograde notion that should
be condemned and that we should be
instituting new corrective curriculums
and our workplaces and in our schools to
try and introduce new ways of thinking a
lot of a lot of those tendencies the
interest in sort of re-education and
realignment it'd be one thing if they
were happening under normal so
Constance's I think the fact that
they're happening under these
extraordinary circumstances makes this
circumstance all the more disconcerting
so I do think it's important to have
these conversations about race and
identity I think it's important to
engage on conversations about structural
racism and yes historic injustice --is
that have perpetuated certain kinds of
inequality but I also think it's
important not to lose sight of that
broader context and the degree to which
mmm rectifying any one of those problems
probably doesn't get us out of the bind
that we find ourselves in great all
right so I want to tell you a little bit
about how I'm seeing this and what I
think we might do about it in particular
right here in this conversation or at
least starting there so my sense is that
race is simultaneously central and for a
good reason and a distraction and that
that is confusing us because you can you
can sort of see one version of the story
in which races some have been
artificially elevated and another
version of the story in which it's the
problem that has to be solved and by
dodging back and forth between those two
perspectives you don't get anywhere
there are several things I heard you all
say Coleman was talking about false
solutions in particular and I think I
said to John McWhorter in the podcast I
I did with him that I believe we have a
an overarching problem which has to do
with the absence of leaders and maybe
it's not even the absence of leaders
it's the conversion of the idea of
leadership into the idea of influencer
and influencer to me is a very much
weaker position and so I know that I'm
looking at a screen full of people that
are capable of leadership at every level
right you're capable of understanding
what a leader must do you're capable of
marshalling the courage necessary to do
it well but the roles you are playing
are ones in which the people who
actually need your insight are
functioning in the role of consumer
rather than said
and that this is just an unhealthy
dynamic so what I'm hoping is to figure
out how we can restore the we can
restore leadership to the place in our
minds that it should exist and then
figure out how to populate it with
people who can handle the responsibility
and my guess would be we have the
ability to do something here we can all
say things that many will resonate with
about race and it's being a distraction
or it's being a key problem that has to
be addressed once and for all but the
other thing we could do is we could
steer the ship directly into the storm
right by demonstrating that it is
possible to take all of the features of
the conversation of race that people are
afraid to have and they are afraid that
if those pieces of the conversation are
raised that the conversation will go out
of control and modeling that in fact we
can do it well and that the result of
that conversation is not itself
frightening that we might be able to
indicate to people that there is a way
out of this which is really the question
John McWhorter was asking what will
happen are we going to see people
figuring out how to stand up or aren't
we and if we don't then what Glenn said
is right we're in very serious trouble
so are you willing to steer the ship
into the storm and deal with the hardest
questions about race and just let the
chips fall where they may
yes let me suggest three questions good
welfare affirmative action and crime
I'll be succinct reparations is a
terrible idea mobilizing a trillion
dollars through the politics of the
state on behalf of a program of racially
defined redistribution is a terrible
idea
very bad for the country South Africa
like categorization of its citizens very
bad for black people setting us up the
possibility of dignity it won't solve
the problem the issue here is
differences in the capacity
to generate wealth if you don't address
it any wealth disparity will really if
you reshuffle the deck it's a terrible
idea
welfare of the 60s and 70s destroyed the
black family welfare of the 20s and 30s
will destroy black dignity affirmative
action it's a fraud black people have
not penetrated the venture capital
industry the cold rioting industry and
Silicon Valley or whatever it is because
not enough black people have exhibited
the skills necessary to succeed at those
tasks the old idea of mid 20th century
that black people being kept out by
animus bias and discrimination is false
development of african-american people
lags
affirmative action is a band-aid crime
the reason that you have so many
incidents is because there are so many
black people breaking the law the police
are operating in these cities as Coleman
suggested in the face of a reality and
outsize level of violence committed by
black people against each other if we
can't be honest about that school to
Prison Pipeline mass incarceration is
systemic discrimination if we cannot be
honest about what's happening in our
communities african-american communities
with the violent criminal behavior that
makes life unlivable for most of the
people here we're not going to get
anywhere so it can we begin this deep
dive by being honest honest about
welfare honest about affirmative action
it's honest about crime I wanna I want
to go deeper than that I hear what you
said and it's not that I disagree with
any of it but I also think it's not the
route the question is why is there
disproportionate crime and I would argue
that we have a systemic problem that is
not fundamentally about race but the
race problem that we genuinely have
plays into this economic disparity
problem in a way that those who have not
reached the bottom rung of the ladder of
course more likely to engage in crime
it's what anybody would do
right if you don't have legitimate
opportunities you will I'm sorry Brett
I'm sorry
excuse me I don't want to know is it
really is it really not patronizing a
community to say of they're criminals
it's what anybody would do when you just
got through saying if someone did that
there are almost no Asians being killed
by the police good all right so let's
let's let's take this apart and figure
out what we actually are saying and what
we actually believe and I of course I'm
open to be convinced that I have it
wrong but my point would be you have a
very different history for people of
African descent who arrived in the new
world and you have a different history
for Native Americans in the new world
and then those two populations have had
unique dysfunction as a result of the
fact that their origin stories are
different than the other populations
that are here and so the only point that
I'm really making it's not that anybody
would do any of these crimes it's that
when you don't have legitimate
opportunities you seek opportunities
that are higher risk nobody wants to go
to prison and you don't choose to engage
in things that will tend to get you sent
there if you have good opportunities but
if you don't you may engage in behaviors
that are likely to run you afoul of the
police and so all I'm asking is I think
one of two things would have to be true
either there's something about the black
population that is more prone to be
criminal or there's something causal
that results in that population ending
up in that category more frequently and
I believe strongly it's likely to be the
latter I've seen no evidence that this
is endogenous right I think you're all
of that is true but I think you're
missing one part and if we're talking
about beat dive this is deep and it's
very hard to quantify and it's partly
why many people refuse to think about it
which is that there's a cultural issue
and it's not about black culture going
back centuries it's not about black
culture or even going back 50 years ago
but there was a turn in the mood in the
1960s where in ways that fascinate me
how this percolated from a small radical
group into a general mood in a whole
community really fascinates me but
something happened between 1960 and 1980
that taught an awful lot of especially
young black men that black authenticity
involved
checking out that black authenticity
means that you get a pass because the
man doesn't like you and as vague as
that sounds the difference between black
culture in 1970 and black culture in
1950 even among the poorest is stark and
unmistakable something happened and we
still have the legacy of that and so to
the extent that you know living in New
York City this is something that nobody
ever wants to say out loud you'll read
in the times you'll hear on NPR you know
seven youths killed last night at a
barbecue and you don't even need to
wonder it's always always black people
in certain neighborhoods now that
doesn't mean there's something wrong
with the people but the question is why
aren't any poor white people doing that
why isn't that happening in poor
Chinatown's why isn't that happening in
many towns in India you know poverty
alone doesn't explain that it's partly
what came to be seen as normal in the
wake of the Black Power moon and also
the expansion of welfare with black
people in mind starting in 1966 which
was pernicious for family relations
although nobody knew that's so I think
you're you're right poverty is one thing
but to the extent that anybody here's
bristling a little bit it's because
there's more there's a black thing and
it's a very hard thing to talk about but
it's there I don't know if all of you
agree with me on this that's my my
take-home I'd like to I'd like to offer
an analysis of of this period I think
that by the way I'm going to say all
this with a great deal of humility
because there several people on this
call are gonna know more about specific
aspects of what I'm gonna lay out here
than I do but this is my sense that it
is up for correction I think that I
think that John John McDuffie was
opposed to john w here is right to pin
our attention to the couple of decades
that followed after the end of the civil
rights seventies in the eighties my
sense is that for most americans on
either side of this well for me
americans there is a sense that or at
least there was a sense
that the black experience in America was
something rotten with state-sponsored
oppression and institutional racism
right up until the moment in which dr.
King was killed and after the passage of
the Voting Rights Act so on and so forth
from that after that however after the
success of the nonviolent movement the
major sort of barriers to meaningful
equality in American life and black
opportunity had been eliminated and at
that point it simply became a question
of our own cultural commitments and
personal responsibilities in terms of
our ability to you know live up to the
opportunities before us and that sadly
the black community has failed to do
that since then on the other hand you
have this other narrative that says that
racism went underground and wound up
being baked into the operations of our
institutions and our systems but it
remained just as pernicious and the
white American majority remain just as
committed to it and so now we have to
pull the structures of society down to
get at the rotted sort of marrow of that
and that's the narrative that you see
proliferating on the Left I think that
there is truth enough in these
perspectives to arrive at some clarity
at what really happened but it's very
complicated in my view this is how I
look at it in the 1960s you had a number
of things happen that sent the cultural
and the structural sort of preconditions
for the sort of developments of a black
culture they'd want have become
self-destructive in many ways that it
was not self-destructive before but that
has to be seen in its interrelationship
with structural aspects of American
society so to go down some examples
hopefully quickly economically speaking
you know I live in Los Angeles Southern
California Black's used to dominate the
agricultural sector and the service
sectors in California and I suspect
other parts of the country with the
Great Society program in the opening up
of immigration policy what they call
chain migration right you had many
immigrants coming from from Latin
America in particular who came in and
dominated the
agricultural in the service sectors us
pushing african-americans out the same
period of time you had manufacturing
opportunities begin to go over the
overseas to places like China and
elsewhere in the late 60s going into the
70s you had many working-class
opportunities for African Americans
begin to contract that's point number
one point number two the entrance of the
Great Society program the the welfare
programs the great victory of the grid
of welfare in the Great Society was that
it eliminated hunger for a good many
people right the Heritage Foundation
would concede that point of successful
in that way what it did not do was
provide an avenue for social mobility it
provided some discretionary income to
African Americans as economic
opportunities were contracting point
number two point number three and it
also became a disincentive for family
formation and that's a very important
thing disincentivizing two-parent
households because you get more benefits
when you're a single parent
point number three eventually as we move
past the assassinations of major black
leaders you have the as we go into the
70s and certainly into the 80s the
advent of heroin the advent of crack
cocaine and a drug based economy that
winds up being serviced by gangs that
initially arise to replace the sort of
black militant leadership of the
community who saw themselves as
defending the community against rogue
police officers but wind up becoming the
distributors of highly profitable
narcotics in a way that in the absence
of Economic Opportunity and social
mobility but in the presence of
discretionary income and systematic
policies that are already undermining
family formation in the black community
become an economic Center in the black
community that is self poisoning and
pushing of this this substance in a way
that further decimates the black family
further decimates black men then also
restructure as much of the cultural
foundations of the community and that
emerges in interaction with the police
response to that epidemic and so you
have the expansion of the police state
you have the beginnings of mass
incarceration that accelerating the 70s
in the eighties
you have a failing educational system in
that moment you have the flight of black
middle-class and black professionals
into integrated communities but leaving
many folks in the inner city all of this
is the immediate ancestor to the anger
and the vitriol we see erupting out of
black America right now but that nobody
is able to positively identify for what
it is it really is a cluster of systemic
forces interacting with our culture in a
way that has pinged us in to
self-destructive behavior and the most
anybody can say about this is that well
this is systemic white supremacy in
action or on the other hand this is just
black people not living up to what they
should be doing for themselves there's
some grain of truth in each of those
things but they are both wildly
simplistic to getting at the truth of
what actually happened to us in the late
60s in the 1970s in the 1980s and even
though most of those problems have
improved since then as a matter of
policy within the black community the
memory of these things are people my
images parents and so forth are on song
khals the memory of all that has been
passed down in a way that makes it seem
particularly for people still living in
watson detroit in harlem etc that these
problems have never improved because for
many of us we are living with the
inherited legacy of the interaction of
these forces so if we can analyze this
in a way that can allow for a
conversation of clarity to take place
around these issues and disenthrall
ourselves from simplistic cultural
explanations on the one hand or while
the alarmists and radical imputations of
racism to just the nation broadly
speaking on the other i think we could
actually get somewhere it may I make a
suggestion operates a frame for this yes
I would like to make a suggestion about
how to do that
I have watched this debate unfold
between people who are focused on
personal responsibility and people who
are focused on systemic causes and I
find a great deal of truth in both of
them but I think we haven't gone back
far enough in history in order to
understand what's really going on and
when I mentioned the special origin
story for people of African descent in
the new world and for Native Americans
the point has everything to do with what
John McWhorter was saying with respect
to culture which is in both these cases
you had a systemic disruption of
inherited culture and a replacement of
that inherited culture with something
that was full of malware in other words
designed to serve the population that
did the install and so in some sense we
are dealing with the outgrowth of that
that do not manifest simply as white
supremacy is as it is now defined in the
minds of white people but it does leave
people with the impression that the
structure itself is unfair and so I
really don't want to dominate the
conversation we've got a ton of
intellectual firepower here and many
different perspectives but I want to
point out one way in which this unfolds
why is there a cultural problem in black
America in part it has to do with
something several of you have identified
which is a glorification of violence
which has something to do with the
absence of fathers which has a hell of a
lot to do with the rate of imprisonment
so I just want to point out to you I
never hear this said by anybody else
it's a biological demographic fact if
you take men out of a population it
disempowers women in negotiations in
mating and dating men who have lots of
sexual opportunity because they're in
high demand are hard to pin down so they
don't play the role of father which
means that to the extent that fathers
are necessary to address questions of
why you should restrain violent impulses
for example their absence then manifests
as increasingly violent crime which goes
to explain some of the patterns that
several of you have mentioned
about an increased propensity for blacks
to kill each other so what I don't
understand is why we aren't having that
discussion right something causes
incarceration of black men and that has
a bunch of predictable effects it's very
straight forward all right okay can I
say something yeah I think you know what
I've noticed talking to friends about
this issue is that it has become a kind
of political chip that is used sometimes
cynically so you know the homicide is
the leading cause of death for black men
in their 20s and even their early 30s
that's not true of Hispanics whites
Asians that's a central problem it's um
I I I'm fairly sure I could persuade
someone that it's it's you know one of
the biggest problems facing the country
a problem a problem that we should have
a national movement to solve there's a
difference between raising that issue on
its own as something one should care
about in itself and raising it as a
reason to dismiss the arguments that
black lives matter is making and I think
when it's raised in that second way
people just Stonewall the conversation
of fully that said even when he raised
it on its own people still Stonewall it
which is which is very depressing but I
think I do think we have to be the
issues obviously are related in certain
key ways but I I do I think there should
just be a conversation in itself about
the first order and second order
consequences of crime not just for the
victims but for the cycle of poverty and
unemployment that it causes
disinvestment any issue that almost
every issue that you will be tempted to
care about related to poverty is made
worse by crime and sometimes you know
mainly caused by crime so there's that
and and the second thing I wanted to say
is that sometimes I feel that these
questions are posed backwards so people
ask why is there such a big difference
in crime between blacks and whites for
example or why do black people commit so
much crime
and I I I want to just insert you know
Steven Pinker's thesis in in a book that
I admire greatly which is the better
angel the better angels of our nature
the which is about the enormous decline
in violence over the past several
hundred years of human history and his
thesis is basically that the question
you should should ask is not why do why
does a certain group of people commit so
much crime but why do low crime
populations commit so little crime
because it could just be true that the
natural state for members of our species
is for young men to get together in
groups and be ready for violence there's
nothing in human history that that made
that that says that behavior is so
pathological that it needs a special
explanation really what needs to be
explained is the fact that we now have
societies where young men don't behave
that way
and as for crime disparities if you look
in the early 20th century and compare
how much crime Irish immigrants were
committing compared to Norwegian and
Swedish immigrants you find disparities
every bit as large as between blacks and
whites today if you look at the crime
disparities between southern whites and
northern whites to this day it's rather
large so so what I want to say is
there's nothing strange or cosmically
unusual about two groups of people with
very different histories different
cultures different circumstances
committing very different levels of
crime and and I'm in a way it's the
wrong question to ask to get to the
bottom of why it is unless of course
you're your solution-oriented
which I am I'm very curious about how we
can lower crime rates violent crime
rates and I'm dismayed that that
conversation is either only used as a
way of dismissing police violence or
just seen as synonymous with racism and
we're going to keep seeing all of these
problems play out until the turn you
know until the end of time unless we
address that central problem
great I know there are several others of
you who are wanted to jump in just like
to make a couple if the first is that I
certainly agree with what John McWhorter
was saying about culture I mean John's
first book losing the race was really
influential in my own thinking when I
wrote my first book about the ways in
which ideas of black authenticity can be
tied up with ideas of street
authenticity and I want to tie that into
the thing that Glen is one of the most
compelling argues that I have ever come
to contact with and so I hesitate to
disagree with him but I do think that
there are ways in which conversation
around reparations would make a lot of
sense and would not be demeaning or of
anything to do with anything like blood
or skin or what we think of as race but
would have to do with specific
population that suffered a specific harm
in a specific society so I don't want to
beat that drum again but it's not about
repairing black people it certainly has
nothing to do with repairing an
immigrant of Nigerian origin or Jamaican
origin has to do with a specific set of
people who can trace themselves back to
American slavery and have been
identified haven't passed out of
blackness it can be identified on
official documents as having been black
and those people usually you can find
people that are still walking around who
have been harmed in certain ways by
government policies whether it be
redlining in their neighborhoods or
what-have-you employment opportunities
it's pretty straightforward to me that
that might not all all of the dynamics
that John was talking about which are
the ways in which oppressed people can
find themselves contributing to their
own oppression through their own choices
but I think that it certainly couldn't
be worse than doing nothing
to that I agree with with Thomas's last
point I actually shared I had a
conversation with the man whose full
name I forget but he goes by Sandy who
wrote a book about reparations
specifically average 4/4
the descendants of slaves and would not
apply to those who were simply part of
the African Diaspora you would have to
prove that you were you actually
identified as african-american for the
past twelve years it would not be in the
form of giving out cash for example
would be getting it would come in the
form of giving out trusts and actually
set up in a way so as to generate wealth
in the black community it would also
come with programs to promote financial
literacy I see no problem with this I
don't think that's the argument that it
would be somehow condescending to black
Americans to do this really holds water
especially when you consider that this
country has given reparations for
example to japanese-americans and I
don't think it was condescending to
japanese-americans to do so that aside I
like to comment a little bit on this
issue of mass incarceration I volunteer
for an organization here in bed-stuy
called children of promise which mentors
kids whose parents are incarcerated and
I can tell you that like there's a huge
dichotomy between the rhetoric coming
out of the quote-unquote anti-racist
movement and the way in which you are
you you are forced to mentor kids who
you know whose parents are no longer in
the home and I think it's just worth
mentioning that if you were to take some
of that rhetoric that is being promoted
in that and so-called anti-racist spaces
and put it in a place like children of
promise you will [ __ ] those children
and you would continue to perpetuate
mass incarceration and violence and not
and so I think just to add that we need
to think about like the psychological
effects of fatherlessness in black
America not only on a mass level but
also just in terms of you know how do
you actually ensure that a child our
mass amounts of children are instilled
with a confidence enough and the sense
of self-worth to actually overcome these
three cycles of poverty in the cycle of
violence that we're talking about
especially if they're looking up to
their parents I thought one hand because
they're their parents
on the other hand they're also like and
I've heard this being said by these
children you know why did this person
leave me why this person neglect me was
it something I did is it my fault so we
have to really think about in terms of
again breaking out of the cycle and
overcoming some of these cultural trends
how to create that kind of psychological
healing within our own community but
also as Americans writ large
I just pick you back one point very
quickly white people are in terrible
shape in America by many measures as
well right now and you know Charles
Marie's book coming apart has tons of
statistics about this all of the things
that people used to say specifically
affected black people and we're so bad
about the out of wedlock birth rate in
the Moynihan report when white society
has come to to do the same thing by
those numbers and we don't have a
conversation about how bad or we we're
not having enough of a conversation
about how bad Americans in general are
doing when it comes to out of wedlock
births the lower classes across the
board struggle with this marriage is
something that's increasingly an
upper-middle-class prerogative for the
educated well employed it's not just
what's not I mean I'm as much of a
critic of of self-defeating culture as
anyone lissa pretend these are uniquely
black problems America looks crazy from
the standpoint of many other wealthy
societies let me piggyback on that let
me piggyback on that
wait what's goes back to my reparations
point you guys here's what I'm saying
about the dignity point exactly
there are a lot of poor whites you see a
lot of wise drug addicts there a lot of
white people struggling there are a lot
of broken white families there are a lot
of white kids who have lost their way
why can't we black people lend our
weight to the real justice problem which
is constructing a decent society why do
we have to carve out a separate
settlement why are we carving out a
separate solomon point 1.2 what's the
settlement has been reached don't come
back here talking to me about America's
racial legacy because you Negros will
have already been paid
you take a sacred obligation rectify the
consequences of our history you can
modify it into a chit and I don't care
what number you put on the chit
then you discharge the obligation by
passing the chill across the table that
is the wrong kind of politics for
America and for black America i I still
disagree I don't I don't think it's a
complete I don't think it's a zero-sum
game when it comes again and I raised
the issue the japanese-americans I don't
understand why I don't understand the
argument that it is somehow an insult to
the dignity or was somehow an insult to
the dignity of Japanese Americans to
give them reparations for a wrong that
was done but that was state sanctioned
and I don't see why that is that
necessarily has cases of completely
different completely different cases
wasn't merely sanctioned it was actual
state state action and I think that
makes it fundamentally different it's
also the case that for the most part
we're talking about reparations that
were paid to specific people for a
specific injury perfect perpetuated by
the state it's certainly true that
slavery and various other sort of
egregious things that have happened to
black people in some instances you do
have the state that's the actor with Jim
Crow it's the state that's the actor but
I don't know that that permitting the
existence of an institution like chattel
slavery for example which is older than
writing is something that really sort of
fits the same bill but I'll take it a
step further I think there's a
fundamental principle that is perhaps
somewhat undermined by taking
culpability and making it something that
is intergenerational and taking even the
injury and making it something that is
intergenerational the the notion of rule
of law is something that is not merely
like good gold or even a sufficient goal
it is a pretty extraordinary thing that
has evaded most people throughout most
of history and to the extent that
instituting some regime of rewarding
people for things that have happened to
their ancestors on account of their
being
black essentially I think that that
might actually impair that fabric and I
know one thing I would say well I'm well
got the mic for a moment is I suspect
there are people who will watch a
conversation like this and will
immediately think that oh they're these
are the folks who talk about culture as
the fundamental problem it's certainly
the case that there are many
unenlightened conversations that take
place around these issues lots of
thoughtless people who invoke culture as
a response and just talk about
black-on-black crime
in a sort of flippant way but certainly
not what's happening here I think the
vast majority of the conversation that
is happening in this country now with
the ascendancy of the anti-racist
movement tends to focus narrowly and
specifically on these structural
problems the fact that the folks on this
particular in this particular
conversation are interested in the
complete complexity of the origin of
those problems and the complexity of
what's required to actually address
those problems whether or not we agree
on the appropriateness of reparations as
part of that solution I think is very
very telling and important and that is
what's happening here as opposed to a
sort of flippant emphasis on on culture
yeah I'd like to pick up on that Camille
and I really appreciate you sort of
distilling that at the end there because
I think that and while I appreciate the
perspectives that everybody is offering
on reparations and I you know I have
sympathy with so much of it I don't
think the question of reparations is is
the fundamental one here because whether
we do or go initiate anything like
reparations eventually it anything we do
or don't do there is going to succeed or
fail on the basis of whether or not we
have a larger framework for the
conversation over race and black America
specifically its relationship to the
structures of our larger society that is
actually able to salvage what is true or
what is even though what has a root of
truth to the different perspectives that
are on offer and these sort of
simplified narratives the question is is
can we
you know this column folks like us can
we help build out a frame that actually
captures of that in a way that can sort
of emerge the coherent narrative that's
that's point number one point number two
is how are we able to grow that frame
that narrative within you know the
larger American conversation and within
the internal conversation in in black
America were the social sort of volition
towards you know a particular type of of
activism is gaining momentum at a an
incredible pace for reasons that are
understandable I think that a frame such
as that needs to sort of find a way to
reconcile sort of the the proper or the
real relationship that exists between
between three things I think one is the
role of culture and in society and human
populations generally but certainly in
black America two is the interaction
between culture and structure and three
it's the interaction between structure
maybe structure and culture but the
variable of whiteness right because that
is something that people are looking at
as a tangible sort of sort of thing here
what is the relationship between these
between these things my sense again is
that culture is sort of the fundamental
question within within black America but
that interacts with a pattern a history
of systemic evolution that excuse a sort
of critical formation in the 70s and the
80s I think and that because of a longer
arc of history and the way in which that
history has moved you have a lot of
people who look at whiteness is having
animated this sort of perfect perverse
kind of evolution of those systems
precisely as you come out in the sixties
during a period of time where we're from
another lids looking at the cultural
impact of Martin Luther King jr. the
nonviolent movement the integration of
the are the the integration of our
popular culture changes that took place
in the south and evangelical community
America became visibly less racist in
terms of how we presented ourselves to
the world really the reality of the
evolution of racial attitudes in
majority for the minds of the majority
of Americans coming out from that period
of time
how did racial attitudes really shift in
white America they shifted I think in a
positive direction but when we account
for whiteness is animating the systemic
depression then you get a very different
frame for understanding that so if we
can blend clarity to those three
variables I think you know what is it
people but mean by whiteness how did
white attitudes change or not change
what is the relationship between systems
and culture and what is the cultural
relationship between culture and success
in black America then we can begin to
build out something that is actually
coherent that can bring in a coalition
behind it so I wouldn't that's
interesting that's it I think that's an
interesting proposal but in my mind it
actually underscores the degree to which
race actually pollutes so many things
and the degree to which the aspiration
to make progress on all of these really
really important incredibly complicated
problems is compounded by the flattening
that the indication of race requires the
the thinking about groups the thinking
about culpability as something that can
be ascribed to one group or another the
thinking about dysfunction is something
that can be ascribed to an entire group
the reality is that there are particular
behaviors perhaps even particular paths
ologies that we want to address and
those pathologies and behaviors exist in
all manner of groups and I think that we
perhaps almost concede too much when we
only have the conversations in terms of
these disparities the the fact that
blacks are over-represented in certain
categories and not have specific
conversations about particular concerns
that we have about particular kinds of
dysfunctions in our society that need to
be addressed um that because the
solutions the remedies again setting
aside reparations for the moment are
generally thing that that are going to
be race agnostic if children
ought to be reading more schools aren't
functioning properly if literacy rates
are too low if hunger is a fundamental
issue in the actual consideration of
race in most of those contexts may not
be all that illuminating it may only
offer friction and that is I think a
really important point for us to at
least consider so I want to what can I
kind of just jump in quickly here I
think a I don't think the problem is
complex I think it seems complex because
we stand in the wrong place
and until you stand in the right place
you don't see that it's actually more
straightforward than you would imagine
and the reparations question is a
perfect one in order to reveal this so I
would argue we should separate it into
two different questions is a remedy
justified and is reparations the correct
that is to say most likely to succeed
remedy available to us in my case I
would say I absolutely believe there is
a justification I do not believe I
believe very much what Glen said that
what you will get if you use monetary
reparations is you will get white
Americans discharging a real debt
without having solved a problem and then
what right that is going to be a
disaster so the real problem the place
that I think we should stand is that
race becomes an issue when the
structures that are supposed to cause us
to cohere as a multiracial society
breakdown as a result of artificial
scarcity when you have scarcity because
something is hoarding opportunity and
well-being we turn on each other
that's natural biological predictable
and so what we are seeing is a symptom
of that hoarding right and we can talk
about the details of how that that
functions within each of these
populations but the real question is why
is opportunity being hoarded how are we
allowing that to happen and what do we
suspect about each other as our reason
to cohere breaks down so Chloe I
interrupted you do you want to jump in
and I really have no idea what that
means I agree with you that that we
should be looking at it sort of is like
a scarcity / abundance model and ask the
questions
why does scarcity exists and what are
the policies both legislative and
cultural that we can enact to rectify
the this issue of scarcity I don't think
that you know to Glenn's point I don't
think that any reparations bill should
be if it were to pass should be an
isolation or set apart from the cultural
question or or other conversations that
have nothing to do with you know a
legislative imposition but I do in
general agree right with your with your
point that the question has to be asked
why is American structure so inadequate
that we are tearing each other apart
what are the areas of scarcity that we
can actually rectify legislatively or
otherwise to help heal that and I do
agree that this exists across the board
and this is not merely a matter of a
racial category if I can if I can just
add one bit of nuance what I'm arguing
for is that we have an artificially high
level of bad luck that the good luck has
been hoarded the bad luck is more
widespread than it should be and it
disproportionately falls on some
communities more than others so it's non
randomly distributed which causes the
impression that we have a race problem
and we do but the race problem isn't
driving this what's driving it is the
fact that there's something that doesn't
want to share and you know we can talk
about redistributing wealth but that's
not what I'm talking about I'm talking
about opportunity and any decent
patriotic American ought to be
interested in opportunity being as
widespread as possible I've literally
never heard an argument that opportunity
should not be widely distributed you can
make arguments about wealth but not not
opportunity and so that's the problem is
if you're going to hoard opportunity and
the lack of opportunity is going to fall
very heavily on some communities that
have a cultural problem that has a long
that is to say multi century history
and a history that is largely
understandable then that's where we have
to go in order to address this so that
we don't continue to have this boil over
every 50 or 100 years question Bret
excuse me
sure the question is okay there's any
quality of resources and there's an
equality of opportunity and it's partly
plays out across racial or ethnic lines
the question here is a question are
there groups that are on top culpable if
the groups that are on the bottom are
themselves in some sense or another
being victimized by society are the
groups that are on the top
vulnerable okay if we fixate our groups
in terms of the inequality of
opportunity or access to luck don't we
have to somehow implicitly indict the
successful even as we offer up our
support for and our concern about those
who haven't done so well aren't there
too many Jews aren't there too many
Asians aren't there too many etc you see
where I'm going with this oh yeah I was
the answer to the question is this is
the thing that is special about America
is that it aspires to allow us not to do
that and we must not do that because
this is this is a very beautiful
structure potentially and a very fragile
one if we start seeing each other in
through that lens and so what I'm
arguing is the villains are not a group
of people it's not Jews it's not Asians
it's not white it's rent seekers right
and some of the rent seekers don't even
know that they're doing it some people
get to the category of rent seekers
through the production of something that
spreads like wildfire and makes them
rich and then being rich allows you to
get richer and you start hoarding
opportunity because it is natural to
want opportunity but it I guess my point
is the the the villains are self defined
by virtue of the fact that they are
interested in yielding their own
children for example from competition
from other people's children all right
it's an American thing to do
and I don't know how successfully I've
answered your question but the thing we
must not do is try to figure out which
population is guilty it's a a bad
question and B it is the route to wrap a
disaster this is that I'm gonna be
really quick is that let's say that you
are correct in this an hour and I really
mean let's say that you're correct the
problem is that the people who talk
about this the most and that the most
authority are highly unlikely to have
that clinical a view of this sort of
thing because there's there's a
different cultural problem which is that
the American intelligentsia is complicit
with encouraging the black segment of
that intelligentsia to have a noble
victim conflicts the idea is that being
a victim is the bedrock of your identity
it's what makes you interesting is what
makes you special and so that means that
even if the opportunity here were
offered and Chloe I'm with you to an
expense on reparation I get it
I see it as you know there is very
similar to the Japanese case my feelings
always been reparations and before and
not too much happened but I could get on
board with the idea that we do it again
but the problem is that the kinds of
people who talk about racism other than
a very few wouldn't be placated by the
racism if opportunities were granted
they would see it as their
responsibility to pretend nothing
significant and what I mean is simply
that I'm gonna pick somebody because
she's in the news a lot lately and
because she really gets around I'm not
choosing her because I think she's
ridiculous I'm just choosing her if
reparations were granted think about
Nicole Hannah Jones on a podcast or on a
TV show think about her general demeanor
which is that of being a warrior against
a major a major tort that has been
leveled a major injustice has been
leveled against her culture think of her
facial expression and I'm not making fun
of it but that facial expression is G
often ads which is kind of similar to
mine actually represent something would
it would it change would it change can
you imagine something
interviewing her in say five years after
reparations happen with her having a
different facial expression and because
this is gonna seem like I'm attacking a
woman I will say the same thing about
Tom Hoshi coats think about his facial
expression in interviews the facial
expression think there's a reason you
can't imagine it ever changing there
would always be that sense that the
battle is still on and unfortunately
that kind of person has such an
influence that I think we need to look
at more than just these cold figures
that you Brett the biologist
understandably are trying to see these
things because the people who talk about
this with influence will never be
placated including if reparations were
granted I think that actually coats
coats just changed since he got really
paid and he's an optimist now yeah I was
going to say cold coats is actually
interesting because he you know when
Obama was in office he had this very
long interview with him in the Atlantic
magazine about reparations where Obama
was specifically saying he actually
wasn't for reparations and just the fact
that he was able to have that
conversation with him without
necessarily it was in print but without
that sort of very rigid you know facial
expression I think is maybe telling but
I think the larger question would be so
how do we disincentivize that kind of a
response culturally and I do think it's
possible because I do think we have a
you know you might not like the term
influencers but I do think we actually
have a lot of influencers culturally in
the black community that are that are
willing and able to have a much more
nuanced conversation about this I
brought this up at a talk that Glenn you
are at it at the Manhattan Institute two
years ago when I talked spoke about The
Breakfast Club for all of its problems
and a husband that was you there are you
know there are serious conversations of
the caliber that we're having right now
from influential folks and the black
community that talk about the problems
with our culture that talk about the
proliferation of violence that talk
about the proliferation of incarceration
as caused by us and so this idea that
there is just none of that happening and
that we can't somehow incentivize that I
just think it's not
laid out by the facts so again my
question and I agree with you John but
my question would be then how do we
distance sensitize that from happening
and maybe maybe come up I saw you
shaking your head maybe you don't think
it's possible but I do so but I would
love to hear you guys his thoughts on
that yeah I mean Chloe is asking the
right question that is the question that
highlights the limitation of the
conversation that we've been having up
to the moment Brett I think that your
frame about the hoarding of opportunity
being a major major part of what leads
to the cultural and other issues that
we're seeing I think that's spot-on I
feel like that overlaps with my analysis
in the analysis that others are are
giving here but I think that the
communicative potential of that analysis
is only made viable if it is deployed
within a larger context that begins to
sort of address the kind of
intercultural and cultural internal
cultural conversations that are already
taking place right because Glenn and
John and in in different ways you guys
are both sort of highlighting the fact
that the empirical arguments are just
not enough right and so if we're gonna
talk about what does a solution look
like from moving the community for it it
can't be a conversation
strictly over what the material
solutions are what is the best version
of reparation should we do abrasions XY
and see kind of wait it has to be a
conversation that actually joins with
the narrative currents that are flowing
out of the black community and other
parts of society and present the reason
I mentioned the idea of whiteness is not
to is not to lend it's not to amplify
and already sort of you know somewhat
toxic kind of concept in the term that
what that in the way in which that idea
is sort of engaged it is rather to sort
of set the stage for a conversation that
allows us to understand that the good
news in American life is that people
generally have gotten less racist over
time and we can look at that and lift up
that truth in a way that perhaps can set
the stage for some sort of
reconciliation here but the other part
that has to be knowledge is the fact
that this systemic the the reality of
systemic problems even if and I myself
don't prefer the idea of it being you
know I don't like the phrasing
racism I don't prefer I don't prefer the
phrase white supremacy but to
acknowledge the fact that there are
systemic problems that are interacting
with the legacy of racism even as
Americans in general have become less
racist over time it sets the safe for us
to have an intelligent policy based
conversation while also being able to
arrive potentially at some deeper sort
of reconciliation in terms of our
personal communal feelings across these
across these cultural divides of black
and right left and right in the ways in
which they they interact and some want
to mention above pursue jon-jon cultural
conversations that way is the way to go
yes go for it John you get it a lot of
airtime listen okay everybody should
read this book everybody should read
Rogers Brewbaker ethnicity without
groups
he's the theoretical sociologist it's an
obscure book it's theoretical sociology
uses art what is nursemaid what to
Rogers Rogers with an S Rogers Brubaker
he says after this ethnic groups don't
just exist they have to be called into
existence through the actions of
strategic actors in the press in the
Academy in the in the in the organizing
community in the gospel and we need to
think about how it is that we frame
issues how it is that they that's what
I've taken from this conversation for
the last 15 minutes critical
institutions mattering the universities
are absolutely fundamental here what's
taught in our universities to young
people who are going to end up being
strategic professional actors and all of
the key venues they're going to end up
Manning and women in the newsrooms you
know they're going to be the young
professionals what's taught by
universities is absolutely critical so
the press is absolutely critical I'm
appalled sometimes when I pick up the
newspaper and I look at the tin ditches
way within which he myths that are very
complicated are framed and simplistic
black and white racial kind of framing
so anyway I just want to make my point
take it as a footnote John would to your
long disposition before you jump in come
on go ahead well I just want to say
before you jump in very frequently we've
got a problem we've got two things that
have been fused together in our minds
and they have to be pulled apart in this
case is it the pointy-headed
intellectual discussion that needs to be
had or is it the visceral narrative
thing obviously it's both you've got to
figure out what's actually going on but
the only way it's gonna reach anybody is
if you get it into poetry or music or
narrative or something like this which
is obviously Chloe's specialty so anyway
I'm not arguing let's get this
intellectually right and then share the
good news because nobody's gonna listen
but if we didn't get it intellectually
right and then figure out how to say it
so that people understand actually
there's hope down some road other than
attacking the nuclear family and taking
apart stem and all of this other
nonsense then you know maybe we can go
in a good direction all right correct
yeah Brett I'm curious how you know it's
the case that our racial tensions are
caused by a as you put an artificial
scarcity and the implication being if if
there were more opportunity our racial
tensions would lessen I'm not convinced
of that I think it might be too
optimistic how do you know that
well a this phone calls pretty good
demonstration all right we're doing all
right
but so is the New York Times op-ed page
so are all the college-educated black
activists class that that is at the
forefront of the misunderstandings oh no
no no that's not what I mean by doing
all right I mean that we are reaching
each other hearing each other making
points concessions all of the things
that are necessary for people to
collaborate in a non race first way but
let me let me flip the thing on its head
because yours there okay let me just I'm
gonna go the analytical rap for a second
until the last five minutes of history
there was only lineage against lineage
competition right people competed with
each other on the basis of who was
related to whom there there is another
mechanism that unfolds which is a
collaboration based on reciprocity right
where one puts aside relatedness and
collaborates based on the fact that it
is profitable to both parties to engage
in collaboration
now that has ancient roots but at the
level of the scale of Nations in general
you have a closely related population
inside of a border and it may compete
with a different population across some
other border or sometimes they're within
one border and you'll end up with a
genocide every now and again but a
structure that attempts to stabilize our
collaborative instincts with each other
and sideline our lineage level
relatedness questions is novel what we
know is that it can work because the
best moments in our history it has
worked and in fact you can see that
moments of productivity are ones in
which we actually make progress on this
front and then you get a contraction and
suddenly we're at each other's throats
so all I'm getting at is the scarcity in
this case is artificial we know that
there's plenty being generated and we
know that it's being very badly
distributed and if we're careful we know
that it isn't just the wealth that's
badly distributed that it's actually the
opportunity and in part you're watching
what we're calling the anti-racist
movement attack many of the solutions
this is a conspicuous tell right the
idea that you would attack the nuclear
family when having two parents is
actually known to be a very positive
factor in terms of pointing kids in the
right direction the fact that it is
attacking academic study the fact that
it is attacking science all of these
things are an indicator that in some
sense it is declaring that it has given
up on the structures that work rather
than tried trying to acquire those
structures for populations that need
them
so did I successfully answer your
question or did I just muddled it not
really I mean I agree with many of the
points you made but I'm so like what I'm
looking for is like this seems like a
very interesting hypothesis to me which
is that what we think our racial
tensions are actually caused by
something totally different it's
something I've actually heard a lot of
activists say that they want us to fight
each other because if we're fighting
each other then we're not fighting them
or them is defined as like you know the
the 1% it's something actually a lot of
Marxists think they think a lot of the
racial issues are actually just class
issues in disguise and if we solve the
former the latter will at minimum be
lessened and I'm I'm curious whether
it's true like have we looked at the
past hundred years of history and seeing
that when when race relations are worse
it's always during economic downturns or
that like how we've done a rigorous that
this this is a kind of thing that sounds
like it might be true but it also just
might be might not be true so I'm
looking for like the rigorous evidence
and well so first of all let's if we can
take this out of the American context
for a second and actually take it out of
the black context as well think about
anti-semitism right anti-semitism is a
recurrent theme in history why have you
ever heard an explanation from Thomas
Sowell his middle man minority that
people don't understand what they bring
economically and resent them it was
pretty pretty persuasive to me but I
haven't studied it rigorously well here
would be my argument I think his
argument is right but that there's a
deeper level and the deeper level is
this Jews live as part of a diaspora it
means that we're a minority population
inside the borders of other nations and
when times are good people collaborate
with us when times are bad they find an
excuse to eliminate us or to steal stuff
from us not because there's any
justification for this but because it
creates growth for the population in a
position to do the stealing and the
population that's in a position to do
the stealing is the majority population
by its very nature so all I'm getting at
is when times are good one can afford to
collaborate because it's not a zero-sum
game it's a positive sum game as things
go into zero-sum or worse
negative-sum you can actually create the
appearance of growth to one population
by robbing a different one and in some
sense what's going on in the u.s. is
that the black population is continually
being robbed right and so the thing that
I'm having trouble with is I'm watching
this movement and it is motivated by
something that I think is very very real
but it has misdiagnosed it and because
it's misdiagnosed it's about to botch
the policy level and in fact it's gonna
botch the policy level in a way it's
gonna take down the entire experiment
rather than doing something that would
positively address the real issue that
has caused the anger which obviously has
a racial nature but isn't entirely
racial right people are suffering in a
very general way so again I feel like I
haven't perfectly answered your question
yeah I don't wanna I don't want to take
up too much time but the the Federal
Reserve recently I think last year did
his economic well-being report it pulls
Americans and asked them are you doing
better financially than your parents and
something like seventy percent of black
people answered that question yes and
that that percentage was higher than for
them for whites and I feel I'm you know
I I'm not sure I buy the idea that this
is a I think this is its own problem is
what I'm saying I think it's a problem
that's generated by ideas by social
media by you know selected by by
coverage bias covering certain instances
and not others but I I I fear that your
analysis might be too optimistic in
pinning it as a consequence of this
other problem well here's a very quick
thing breath yeah I I would have to
agree with Coleman here in that I
suggest a heuristic I say this all the
time on the Glenn show but I think this
is important whatever you're trying to
come up with about race problem whatever
analysis you're trying you have to
always keep in mind this very simple
thing every summer in big cities across
the United States black teenagers and
twenty-somethings start killing each
other in alarmingly high numbers over
nothing at all
now whatever explanation you have based
on the
or opportunity or who has more of the
chips the question has to be why that
because I don't think anybody would say
I don't think you would say that those
boys are killing one another because
they don't have enough to eat because
they're not making as much as their dad
there's something more going on and it's
not to say that these are ethological
individuals there are there reasons for
this it's a tragedy and you want them to
stop this but what's going on among many
other things is that and so your
analysis has to cover that well of
course it does and I mean look there's a
really bitter pill that comes with the
analysis that I'm preparing to foster
for one thing I don't think very much
depends on the precision of it right
which I think is what we're arguing
about the question is is it is it in the
ballpark is it accurate the problem is
that so much of this is deep enough that
the solution is not quick there is
nothing that you could deliver that
would solve this in less than a
generation you could start to make it
better very quickly but you can't you
can't solve this because the problem
does involve a failure of the culture of
fatherhood for example you have to
resurrect the nuclear family not attack
it right you have to resurrect a respect
for meritocracy for achievement and
achievement in order to resurrect a
respect for it it has to be possible so
the question is if people don't see that
there is a way for them to get ahead by
being personally responsible they don't
engage in it and so there has to be
something to shoot for and that's true
too that's quite it is it is it your is
it your position right that there is not
a sufficiently meritocratic system in
place today when you talk about this
this deficit of opportunity is it a
function of just lower productivity
during the period that we find ourselves
living in or these thick do you think
that there is something that is broken
because certainly when I look at when I
look under the hood of what we call
black America and we look at the various
cohorts that exist there the different
immigrant communities there
lots of successful people there and I
think that's also true across the United
States when you tick off certain boxes
and when you have certain
characteristics you actually tend to do
pretty well in this country and you can
have attained some of that upward
mobility
I think there's there are things
certainly prior to the pandemic that
we're working there are other things
that weren't working and you know one
concern that I have is is the degree to
which we imagine that that we can
engineer the better political systems
that will give us better societal
outcomes and I think a lot of the
political fixes like the affirmative
ones that that we often imagine putting
into place to try and uplift people out
of poverty and to to better distribute
opportunity they tend to fail in ways
that are pretty profound and for reasons
we don't understand because the
mechanisms that actually allow us to
create prosperity her there they're
distributed and they're very difficult
to actually try and game and they're way
too complicated for most of us to
actually understand well so this I think
is where this dynamic between
conservatives who tend to favor personal
responsibility solutions and liberals
who tend to favor systemic solutions
tends to to to go awry because there is
clearly if I was advising somebody who
was in an oppressed population I would
be full-time on the personal
responsibility issue right why because
you have a very good chance of improving
your well-being by being personally
responsible whether it's fair or not you
have a very good chance of getting out
of your situation if you can keep your
head down and do the right sorts of
things so if I was advising an
individual that's the only game in town
the problem is if it doesn't adjust how
much there is available then if you
succeed through personal responsibility
somebody else fails somebody whose name
you don't know right and so my
point would be it's not one or the other
in this case from the point of view of
individuals we don't want this D
individuated anti-racist movement that
basically turns people into you know at
just of a mob we want people to
recognize themselves as individuals and
to recognize that they have agency and
and that's important but to the extent
that the problem is at the end of the
day if there is enough to go around it
isn't available to most people that's an
issue to be addressed at a different
level and I am NOT I was decades ago a
believer in these architected top-down
solutions I am no longer a believer in
those things that's not what I'm
advocating but I am advocating that we
recognized a degree to which bad luck
for example is non randomly distributed
and we say look that's just an
unacceptable phenomenon right it is our
obligation there's gonna be bad luck but
it should be evenly distributed based on
race and zip code and all of these
things and until it is we've got a
problem that can be addressed at a
different level that personal
responsibility does not have any impact
and I was thinking we talked about bad
luck right I was reading some of the
bios of those individuals who were
killed who we're doing you know personal
responsibility who were taking care of
their families who just so happened to
be at the wrong place at the wrong time
and we're shot by us killed by a stray
bullet and what is the piece of
legislation that's going to effectively
change that bad luck well so first of
all there's a deeper problem and you're
right the focus on culture in this
conversation is I think key and I want
to tell you a very brief story I was on
a subway in Harlem last time I was in
New York and there was a group of kids
they must been 13 14 years old
seemed like interesting good kids
they were black and they were horsing
around on the train and one of the kids
a girl
sort of looked a bit bookish and the
other kids that she was with took her
knapsack and they started making fun of
her for studying and giving a damn about
school and they literally turned her
backpack upside down and spilled out her
notes just spilled out across the floor
of the Train and she was embarrassed
picking them back up because it
demonstrated that she gave a damn right
that's a deep problem right that's a
serious problem because it means that
even somebody who is interested in the
kinds of things that does allow them to
that would allow them to deploy personal
responsibility and and lift themselves
up by their bootstraps faces something
else which is that if other people are
around if you don't have the same
capacity they may even resent your doing
it so this is deep stuff it doesn't it's
not just legislation but if you were
gonna do it legislatively what would you
do I would think instead of reparations
we'd be talking about massive investment
in these communities it's not like we
don't know how to build a good school
right they just don't happen in certain
neighborhoods and they do happen in
other neighborhoods and it's not an
accident which neighborhoods have the
good ones and if you really want it to
solve this problem and you were willing
to invest 20 years to do it then placing
the things in the locations where the
tools that are most useful are
accessible is at least a prerequisite I
see it's not it's not a racial white
kids that I grew up white Italian
Americans that would do the exact same
thing they throw your books on the
ground you have a problem of discussing
class in terms of race in America there
is not this is not inherently black
behavior I know that this is so but no
but it's the idea of acting white is
something that affects I've you know
I've experienced it but it's not it and
it's sort of fundamentally black thing
is that it's a work thing JD Vance talks
about this in hillbilly elegy you know
we need to find a language that this was
we have to find a language that doesn't
include the problem bye-bye-bye this
kind of hocus-pocus talk of race I hope
I hope you don't think that that's what
I'm saying it happened that the kids I
was looking at on this train were black
but that's not what I'm saying at all
and in fact I think what I said earlier
in the Congress
is that as soon as we start seeing these
things as Rachel we lose sight of what's
actually going on and we default into
this ancestral mode which problem it's
it's excuse me Thomas I just wanna make
this point it's a network phenomenon
it's about individuals embedded within a
social structure of interpersonal
contact now those tend to be racial
given racial identification and racial
organization of society they're not
intrinsically racial but they are in
their manifestations de facto often
racial exactly Bret the reason I was
shaping shaking my head was because
whether that phenomenon is racial or not
and that's a very complex question I
think it's worse and more dangerous in
the black community than say Thomas
among working-class Italians because
there's a whole issue that that girl
with the glasses are supposedly not
black not just nerdy but nevertheless
let's just call it anti intellectualism
the sad fact is that when that kind of
culture is entrenched in a school you
can put money into it for a generation
and you go back in a generation and the
place is still a mess that has been
shown in there's a tragic case in st.
Louis and then there was another tragic
case just in New Jersey pump money into
those schools and have telescopes and
people learning how to make sushi and
all of that and if the culture is such
that school is seen as alien the problem
it's not solved and I wish that much
actually I agree with this let me just
say and you would find it funny if you
saw the classroom that I ran before the
Evergreen meltdown because the Evergreen
the classroom that I ran didn't look
like school for exactly this reason I
was not a good student and so I'm not
suggesting we just duplicate some good
school in a bad neighborhood I think we
have to reinvent
like that a lot and I would say that
there's something you said a moment ago
we know how to build good schools and
I'm not so sure about that we we know
where some good schools are we know what
the qualities of those good schools are
but those schools tend to
that in particular context they fit the
particular they had cultivated a culture
over time perhaps some mechanisms for
inculcating that culture within the
professor the leadership and the
students themselves they're complex and
the actual mechanisms that get us to
better institutions are likely to be the
same things that get us to better goods
and services it's probably greater
competition it's probably greater choice
in the in the context of education and
it is most certainly an environment that
encourages innovation which is something
that we have not seen in K through 12
education or in higher education neither
one of these things has changed
materially in in the past hundred odd
years and K through 12 in particular
it's not even like the material that
we're teaching is much different yet we
still see falling test scores in certain
context for whole swaths of the
population and we still have these
incredibly inefficient Meccan
circumstances where we used to anyways
fill classrooms with 30 kids give them
textbooks and sometimes laptops and
calculators and it's not terribly
different than the way it's from the way
it's worked over the course of the past
century anyplace else in America and I
do think that we need to break that old
model and find new ways of educating
students but I also think that this
process is hard and it is likely to be
something that needs to actually grow
organically in order to work a last
point on this is that it is very clear
to me that the most beneficial thing
that's happened to any student who's
been trapped or who had that ran the
risk of being trapped in an
underperforming school over the past 30
40 years is the advent of school choice
and a charter school movement and we
need more programs like that to actually
improve their circumstances and here
again you know we're having a narrow
specific conversation about a particular
aspect of you know the problems that are
often thrown in to this bucket of things
that are beautiful a chimera
or you know the repercussions of
structural racism in this country and I
just think that those conversations tend
to be a lot more productive and they
tend to yield a lot more in the way of
remedies and I I'm I am at least a
little bit pessimistic about the broader
global projects to try and create a new
language for us to talk about these
things and as much as I engage in some
of the intellectual aspect of this
routinely I do think that it's the
practical mantras it's the simple
slogans that end up getting it done it's
Martin Luther King's assertion that he
has a dream and the specific idea in
that dream being that we would all be
judged by the content of our character
like that resonates with people that has
legs and I think that is to the extent
you're uncomfortable with the current
moment and the wave of anti racism and
the degree to which it essential eise's
us you're uncomfortable with it because
of that idea that piece of software that
that travels really really well well I'm
not sure what you mean I'm uncomfortable
with it I'm concerned that we are about
to uninvent America and that the horror
that will replace it is something that
thought of frighten us all but I agree
with you completely about what you said
about school what I should have said is
we know how to make better schools we
don't know how to make good schools and
it's very important that we figure it
out and it should look radically
different but then I say something bread
just quickly I'm struck by the contrast
so there are two big areas of public
service provision which have massive
impacts on black communities its
policing and education both of which are
unionized both of which are provided by
public employees and so forth and so on
and both of which it could be argued and
failed the community look at the
discourse within the community about the
failure of public institutions to
measure up to the needs of the people
with respect to police we've got defund
the police
we've got throwing bricks at cops we've
got what we've got we've got black lives
matter with respect to education
you have the left-of-center politics
implacably opposed to doing what Camille
Foster just said needed to be done
the to fighting to the last man to keep
it from happening now my point is not
about them I expect them to defend their
interest my point is about us where's
the criticism of that for people who
think that black lives matter can you
say what exactly the criticism what is
that in that sense that is the failure
of conventional public educational
services being provided to black people
to convey to them the opportunity in
this life to which they are entitled so
this is why which can be remedied
Camille suggests by expanding
educational choice which policy is
implacably opposed by the Democratic
Party so I believe the problem is both
parties that the parties have
effectively got a stranglehold on power
right and that stranglehold on power
means that policy does not serve the
public and it hasn't for decades so this
is why I started where I did I believe
if you were to get anywhere if Camille
is right about what the solution
actually looks like then what you need
is a governmental structure that
actually gives a damn what the
consequences of its behavior are rather
than parties that are cynically pointing
us at each other so that we don't notice
the corruption that they're involved in
that I really think is ultimately the
only route out of this because if we let
the parties continue to play their role
they're going to start a race war I mean
very predictably no no because that's
not true no I think the Democrats are
basically cynically toying with
partnering with this so-called
anti-racist movement and that that is
going to back White's against the wall
and cause them to start seeing things
racially in a way that they haven't in
more than a generation and that the net
result of those two phenomena is that we
are going to be headed to a conflict
that nobody knows the way out of
and what's more unlike our first civil
war there's not even a geographic
description of a solution right it's not
about that because you have quite a lot
of whites that are no longer interested
or exhausted in their own identity who
are not going to be taking up that war
so it gets a lot more complicated than
white respect I agree it's more
complicated but do you see a way that it
ends acceptable I mean you have a
well-armed rural white population that
is now correctly understanding that it
is being targeted by a mob that claims
it's guilty of all sorts of things that
it actually isn't guilty of yet and
threatening to redistribute the
opportunity that it has it's it's a
catastrophe unfolding in slow motion of
the population that is so well-armed
generally speaking is probably not the
same segment of the population that is
enjoying all manner of privileges and
opportunities that's exactly what I'm
saying the people the people who are in
the rent seekers who I believe are the
self defined villains here the rent
seekers would rather that we fight each
other they would rather that people of
average means both white and black and
every other description that we fight
each other and that we not notice where
the opportunity actually went that's the
yeah I I hear the I hear the argument
and I I understand I understand that
which are advancing I do wonder though I
don't have to suppose any kind of
cynical or sinister motive on the part
of the lawmakers in Detroit who
continually failed the people who
elected them to office to try to improve
their circumstances over the course of
the last 50 or 60 years and it's
possible they've even instituted
policies that people want there to the
best of their ability and those policies
might still fail I don't know that most
people have a very good sense of what
works and what's likely to yield the
best outcomes I'm not certain that you
know Democratic outcomes are even
necessarily going to give you the best
outcomes I think a lot of
would like to see someone take all of
the money and give it to the schools and
an engineer a good outcome it's it's
just not obvious to me that that that is
actually consistent with getting wit
'let's just narrow this to education
again a competitive innovative choice
driven educational system I think most
people are far more comfortable with
something that is universal and is
equitable in the sense that you at least
you know you know you're getting a token
and it's funded corporately by all of us
and perhaps is consistent with the
status quo but I don't think I don't
think you're hearing what I'm saying it
I don't think the Democrats have the
solution I think they've gone stark
raving mad right but I do know that the
way you would discover the solution is
you would have to eliminate the
conflicts of interest and then have a
discussion in which the proposal that
you're making is on the table and it's
defended in terms that are you know
analytical so it is it is necessary to
eliminate the corruption in order to
figure out how much we know about what
to do and to discover that which we
don't yet know so that's really my point
is it's the corruption that is causing
the problem and until we deal with that
one
we don't know how much solution making
is readily possible I'm sorry they're up
but are we thinking of concluding soon
because I only allow two hours for this
I think we have to do that do people
have five more minutes yeah just I want
to very briefly say I said st. Louis I'm
in Kansas City for anybody who wants to
check up on that case thanks for the
correction so how should we use the last
five minutes I can talk about corruption
and what I think we should do or we can
continue the discussion and you guys can
wrap up what you've heard and what you
think it means I just want to add to
support what Camille just said I'm not
sure that the corruption is merely top
down in the sense that like I it could
be that we the citizens have not we
don't have this like internal feeling of
actually do like
fulfilling our duty as citizens and
holding our politicians feet to the fire
and so that pays that pick that plays a
prominent role in terms of stopping the
corruption that you are referring to
Brett and I and I that's not something
that's easily solved
who's up yeah my mind the cultural
question with cultural question in terms
of the larger narrative question really
is what's what's key I mean Camille
mentioned doctor dr. King the simple
principle of us being judged by the
content of our character but King
engaged in a larger narrative project
that challenged both the narrative
coming from the races establishment but
also the narrative coming from the
militant establishment of the civil
rights movement and basically the whole
spectrum of the humanizing perspectives
in a way that that shifted the
conversation in America but bore fruit
in the actual cultural lives of
Americans left right and center black
right etc to me that is that is the key
question that is the key project and
that's what I hope folks on this call
would focus on great is next I just said
I think that in America we live
extraordinarily segregated lives still
and the only way that a lot of these
problems are going to be solved is how
is if we figure out how people can meet
each other on more equal terms so I come
back to I think I'm agreeing with what I
think you were getting at right is that
there has to be some form of material
equalization going on before we'll ever
figure out to the vision that still
plagues us great Coleman I can't help
but feel like there are various ways of
trying to say that this problem is
actually another problem in disguise
whether that's political corruption or
lack of Economic Opportunity or economic
inequality and I I'm left feeling
unconvinced by those I'm
feeling that this problem is hopelessly
self-generated and will outlive and
persist in in spite of our being able to
potentially solve or make progress on
all of those other issues I think it's a
problem of perception it's a problem of
beliefs that are often that often have
no other cause outside of the inherent
appeal of the beliefs themselves beliefs
about what what it means to be a
one-race rather than another beliefs
about what you inherit by virtue of
being one race beliefs about how much
racism there is in society so I yeah I'm
I'm I am I I think it's very interesting
to consider the possibility that there
actually caused by something else that
we can focus on some root cause of these
issues but I'm I'm left feeling that
they're hopelessly self generated before
I asked someone else to step in let me
just say root causes one way to look at
it but basically failure mode is another
that a lack of leadership and political
corruption are two sides of the same
coin and that in effect until you have
solved that problem you're you're
navigating blind right little works some
some interests that are above the public
interest are steering and it results in
failure after failure and so I hear your
hopelessness but what I want to convince
you of is you know to the extent that
somebody has hooked up the controls in
the control room backwards solving that
one thing actually immediately has
downstream consequences that are very
positive I want to identify with : and I
and I'm not sure I agree with you Brett
and and here's why I'll be very concise
shut down stem ok so the problem here is
an intellectual identity problem it's
not a resource problem it's not people
being poor who are the people who is
saying shut down stem there graduate
students and biochemistry at Stanford
there are some of the most privileged
people of color on the planet there be
like the beef of every newsroom that has
a plurality of african-american
journalists will fire an editor if he
runs the wrong op-ed piece is up here
it's not in their belly it's in their
heads they have the wrong ideas I don't
think at the end of the day materialism
is going to get us to where we need to
go I would have to agree with with Glenn
and you know Clint and I sometimes do
that at some times don't this question
is not primarily about resources and
that's what makes it so damn hard
because I think modernity and diversity
bring with them unusual frames of mind
that I think psychology and sociology
are just beginning to catch up with
there are ways of thinking that seem
counterintuitive from the outside and
yeah we have to think of for example the
affluent black kid at Stanford who same
shutdown's them they're there they're
not hungry they haven't been denied
anything it's an ideology it's a
peculiar self-serving comfortable and
destructive ideologies that you wouldn't
think a group of human beings would
embrace unless you think about the fact
that it can only often emerge when
resources are distributed relatively
effectively that's the challenge that we
have these are very very modern people
they they are but I would just point out
shut down stem which was particularly
galling and frightening is not organic
it is a demonstration of power getting
people to say shut down stem getting
scientific establishments to say shut
down stem was a demonstration of the
amazing power of this movement and you
can't necessarily assume that the people
who are saying it are saying it because
they believe stem doesn't work they're
saying it because they're serving
they're trying to get out of the way of
a mob or they're trying to their
wrongheaded and they're trying to serve
that movement and so they're saying
things that make no sense but I guess
what I would wrap up with is I would
just say look I have moments of
hopelessness too
and I do see a problem that's going to
be very difficult to solve however the
ability to think clearly without
conflicts of interest is a prerequisite
to solving it it's not sufficient but it
is necessary and so I would urge you all
to consider what do we lose if we solve
the corruption problem and it turns out
not to be sufficient we have lost
nothing because we're headed for a
disaster anyway if we solve the
corruption problem and it turns out that
it is causing us to be unable to think
about what good solutions might be what
they would look like unable to innovate
as Camille said then we potentially have
a bright future ahead of us so I would
just say I hear your doubts I share them
but holy hell we're headed for very very
dangerous waters and we might as well do
the one thing that makes obvious sense
which is restore our ability to think
without conflicts of interest yeah we'll
say maybe perhaps building a bit of a
bridge that I I do find your
observations about leadership and the
interesting development with respect to
the role that these leaderless political
movements are playing in society that
combined with the way that we're
communicating with one another now it
does strike me as something that is more
than just a little novel it's this is a
pretty substantial development and it
may very well be that a lack of having a
significant personality in the
intellectual landscape that can actually
help to direct some of these energies is
a real deficiency perhaps even a danger
that we might want to try to
deliberately rectify so right that's
very interesting all right so I would
just point out we all know we all know
that neither Donald Trump nor Joe Biden
has the answer here and I think we all
know that we don't necessarily have four
years to wait for a solution that makes
sense so I would ask you all to consider
something like the Unity 2020 proposal
for rising above politics and fixing
this problem directly
okay take a look at it appreciate that
really do and I appreciate all of you I
appreciate your courage your generosity
of spirit your willingness to engage in
a very dangerous exercise and your
patriotism
so thanks folks I hope we can do this
again soon Thank You Brett thank you so
much bread all right be well so long
[Music]
[Music]